hello patreon haha
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we're
gonna watch this video a music video
mainland I found God and I hear they use
real couples in it they use real God
real gods in it yeah I found a God let's
let's I have no idea what this song is
actually about I have no idea what any
of this is about but I'm willing to
watch it
[Music]
[Music]
look my way I can see your reflection on
the floor intentions only water let me
drink your perfection neighbor do I know
your name too is gone now breathing the
fire you
we divide our desire sheets fly by snow
friction to the choir hey girl now you
know my name
[Music]
rather you run wherever you go I I want
you I need you to know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's okay to be black and gay it's
okay to be anything real and straight -
I got a straight-up cried like you know
one of the two more passages I might
have actually started into the right
anything with love makes me cry
yeah well and you know the immediacy of
the way that video kind of takes its
shape because the first you're sort of
like yeah and then and then yeah when
they all start to find each other you're
like oh yeah and that's that's that's
kind of a clever thing yeah because you
start with all these disparate these
these different people separated from
each other and then you start to wonder
who's gonna come together and what is
that all gonna look like yeah yeah yeah
it's like you're meant to be with that
person yeah yeah that is beautiful yeah
no it's a good sentiment like I actually
like that really touched my heart yeah I
did was when interesting experience when
I said what he said I thought I said
bullet yeah I mean that was like bullet
that's a nice occasion he said body like
and then immediately my dark state
suicide right state yeah you know cuz
it's called I found God so I didn't know
he was gonna be like a religious context
of a song yeah and or you know just a
map I love that dog
I do too I call that dog Satan what were
we saying you know just generally
talking about oh yeah cuz the video and
and we I think the last point we may was
it sounded like it could be big it just
can be religious and
and I feel like there's other ways to
feel closer to what we call you know the
higher source the higher power or God
yeah and you know I've one way is
through creativity you know like God or
whatever it is that you believe as a
creator being creative is a way to feel
connected to another higher source
timely references and another way is
through just human connection and love
is the open is probably one of the most
powerful form of finding a connection to
God so I didn't know if we were even for
like some religious Christian song
I'm sure than fine there's some career
I'm not I don't concern myself a
catheter or even like a follower of
Christianity but there's some Christian
songs I get into and if our God is for
us and so I would have been fine with it
but I've never like quite like moved to
tears by like a Christian song because
yeah it's a niche so yeah the song of
love and acceptance and feeling that
euphoria of that connection to what life
is all about yeah I really feel that
with the combinators the song in itself
I would have liked a lot and the song if
I just heard the song if I was like
listening to in the car would have
really appreciated it but with the music
video complementing it is a very you are
on the journey because you're like who
she can end up with is the girl can end
up with you know yeah and I think
knowing that as I read the text on
YouTube saying it was everyone was a
real couple real couples made it even
more powerful yeah no totally when you
said that I that was probably the most
beautiful thing about it cuz like
they're all so different
yeah you do start to wonder that that
makes that that hook makes the progress
of the video more fascinating cuz you do
start to go who is what are the real
couples who's gonna end up with who and
some of them you're like oh yeah I can
kind of I might have guessed that and
some like oh wow I wouldn't
yeah yeah yeah you know it is beautiful
I like how it's a combination of all
kinds of couples you got hitter racial
you got gay you got straight yeah you
know there might have been a couple
transgender people in there like yeah it
seems like everybody was kind of
represented you had a man an animal that
guy in his turtle true love right there
[Music]
who is this guy
mainland mainland the song is by
mainland as that was fantastic great job
mainland mainland
great great job you know John I was
thinking of putting this on just patreon
alone I might put this on youtube as
well powerful video that I would love to
I mean we put a lot of great pride a
great commentary on other pages videos
and there's a patron of videos where
we've teared up at or I teared up at the
friggin America's Got Talent our fillet
instead yeah cuz I'd like to spread the
message more spread the word oh yeah
the Gospel according to Mark praise be
to God when it's nice to separate
yourself from the idea that God's just a
white dude with a beard in a robe you
know well yes he is truth but you know
it's nice to pretend that he could just
be the love you find it yeah buddy I'd
rather be in denial and believe that
yeah I'd rather conform to an antiquated
belief system and I was given as a child
for myself you know well just in case
subscribe to the rail rejects and cook
that notification bow take care of
people check out more mainland music and
you know look I button love some time